yeah welcome to this five-minute game
let's play the car card once again and
dumb you try with the price teen Larson
shop c4 I really forgot what's the move
maybe I just develop this shouldn't be
too bad push up a force a strange move
not sure what it is doing on a four
besides weakening be too so should i am
not sure maybe i should play a five or
so probably I need to Castle on here so
so I'm not a great idea to weaken the
Queen side
yeah do i cancel long I'm not sure maybe
this is still interesting idea a form as
a threat taking be too and maybe you can
cancel I cannot really take me to yeah
this I thought I have this this reply c3
I can take yeah this is necessary what
now we are probably retreat the bishop
and put how to continue outside curious
yeah it doesn't look too great to
retreat it but I want to play 925 night
be 65 and maybe we should be 62 to
exchange their for Bishop
yeah the ad will have a nice place on d5
attacking the bishop and it's not so
easy to to get rid of it on d5 because
he doesn't really want to place you for
answer the insertion of a five and a
four s we can befall so much some of the
nidus pretty much on a rock on d5 yeah I
suspected this is completely incorrect
as usual people simply sacrifice
incorrectly all the time and it's
amazing often they get away with it this
is not working for for multiple moves
and this is just one of them why doesn't
even have a threat here I just play 27
next move and it's over quindi 70 where
do you go from the m2 e2 of wealth
yeah I needs to go to eat too i mean
everything else is a queen trade and you
don't want wanted to play this on even
with the with the earth Queens exchange
okay so Bishop g7 as a sort of half a
threat here my castle long is maybe a
going see form I've probably probably
this one attacking situate cannot lose
the support because of 253 yeah I
thought that this should defend now
please havilland rupee aid should get
the piece back he's got three points but
it's got the King on on f1 rook on each
one it probably wasn't the best way to
to counter the sacrifice that's why
didn't I play take c7 it's much easier
much easier ah completely unnecessary
yeah the sauce was much easier way to
play Jay no this is still something that
needs to be played
and winning the default poem 94 so a
threat now I want to if possible win the
B porn with the rock rock be to land use
them King and 94 for defense god I
miscalculated unbelievable but this is
still 0 km time warning check
it almost made up winning the rock this
is also an Isaac who Jack Jack you know
I'm glad I I managed managed at the end
it always feels completely sick to lose
against what's this kind of nonsense I
mean it's obvious that that is not
working I mean why would you nap okay
sorry and it's probably not even the
best one I did Bishop see to wear this
is immediately winning okay just making
sure that that the night has never ever
kicked on d5 yum okay but this is this
is also strong I just I need to take C 2
yeah I didn't want to use a move with
their with this but it's um it's simply
am it simply the best tool to get this
fantastic knight on d5 which never can
move the point is some point is I mean
Tweedy seven wins as well but this is
this is easier even look at this and now
this is very strong
I trap this ms Bishop ago okay that this
is difficult to see at least I'm in a in
a blitz game and now i'm getting the
bishop back end and just windows with 22
pieces against the rook and fantastic
pieces on d5 two bishops some excellent
for black the game this is winning as
well but this is not not the best one
probably you need to need to do
something else you have long castles I
was afraid of c-4 but I didn't see a
Bishop b4 and it's so good with this
thread they are very strong or just take
it it's an exchange and nothing for wide
yeah and this is some this keeps keeps
the advantage but it soon and this is
just idiotic why didn't I take here why
just resigns after that they are not in
great shape yeah I hope you enjoyed the
fried anyway thanks for watching